[Music]
wow
[Music]
hello
hello hello
i'm back in studio first thing that
happened when i came in is everyone was
playing smash brothers again i like
smash brothers as much as the next guy
like woohoo go captain falcon right but
i'm starting to get concerned about the
amount of time that's going into this
they play like three to four times a day
it might be upwards of maybe an hour
we put a lot of time into smash bros on
the clock
that's just what it is i'm concerned
about the level of productivity that it
drags down
in japan there's this technique called
the pomodori technique which is a work
technique where you have a tomato timer
which is called pomodori i guess in
japanese and you turn it all the way up
for 60 minutes and then when that timer
is done you take 10 minutes to do
something else wind it back up to 60
minutes and go back to work for another
60 minutes and repeat until you're done
with your task after an hour of hard
work you need a solid 10 minute moment
to clear your mind and refresh your
mental state before you get back into
things especially when doing creative
work this is really important we
discovered that smash brothers was a
perfect little 10 minute break well
first of all smackdown is like the best
video game ever invented and i'm very
glad that there's a big group here at
the office that is into it because i
literally get to train smash bros daily
playing smash is a good way to just kind
of relax take a break and then go back
to work feeling confident knowing how
much better i am than everyone else it's
good to reward yourself with a little
bit of like all right don't focus for a
little bit if you let them play then
they go back and they work hard
afterwards but if they don't play then
they're like that at their desk and how
can you edit if you're itching your neck
you know most days i'm just a lowly
editor but when i'm playing smash
brothers and when i'm destroying
everyone i actually get to be who i was
always meant to be a god
perfect in every way
jakes wants us to stop playing smash
brothers i don't know what i'd do
without smash brothers so i have an idea
to circumvent this we're going to have
peter come up with a new smash brothers
or smash brothers completely from the
ground up
is everything okay yeah please have a
seat
so i need to be frank with you you have
a natural passion for creativity and
making games in this case i have a
natural passion for being efficient so
together we could create something that
does both of those things i i want to
make a game that's genuinely fun maybe
we can compromise by making the players
just feel a little bit guilty every time
they play great i love that i was raised
catholic so that is perfect subliminal
messaging that's a good idea maybe every
time you get a smash on somebody it's
like back to work
like a weird italian accent you're on
the clock
or like
daniel's still working right now yeah
daniel's still working in unreal you can
load up a live stream and have daniel
working in the corner you take the
number of people playing and you
multiply that per second by the amount
of money it costs the business per
second and then that number is just
ticking in red if i saw how much i was
costing the company by playing smash i
honestly probably would not play as much
alright dude well i think this is really
good progress i think it's a great
compromise you know
not fired
i didn't know that was in question we
have to talk in private
look i love smash brothers i heard you
guys making a game here yeah we're
making our own with the sole purpose of
making people not play and get back to
work look i i've tried that before i
made clint of meditation space uh-huh
did it work
like after that
i just felt bad i felt so guilty working
in all these subversive elements trying
to get them back to work i failed on
this task and i'm just saying it's a
dangerous place to go i think you might
actually want to make this game fun
still
it's just kind of confusing for me
because i'm getting conflicting
directions from my two bosses yeah yeah
i know it must be tough i'm honestly
stuck in between a rock and a hard place
right now i got one boss telling me to
make this game super fun and one boss
telling me to make this game super not
fun i think i just gotta dive into these
blueprints start figuring it out
[Music]
it's 1106.
i don't ask a lot around here i ask
people to get here at 10 30 to give me
eight hours of work today i'm gonna time
all the smash breaks and see what we
actually end up at i've been working on
unreal stuff unreal is a really awesome
piece of software because it's like any
other 3d software but you can do really
easy coding in it because as opposed to
writing your code with text and having
to memorize all this random crap it's
node based coding just looks like this
full blocks that you plug together and
it's very approachable and so i made
this little third-person shootie game
with clint as the main character but as
i like to call him blind because he has
the booty the big voluptuous booty it's
a basic little game but you know it was
just so i could get my feet wet and
unreal and kind of learn the software
and i feel like i've gotten to a pretty
good point do you want to play the game
do i want to play the game yeah i've
been waiting for this
oh my god
oh there's another dean
[Applause]
look at that booty run oh my goodness oh
we call that rump runner rump runner
dude ryan why don't you try a double
jump whoa oh my god
oh my god what is that it's a giant
what is this look it's your head i
honestly forgot it was in there
you know having completed this little
game i feel like i have enough skill and
experience under my belt to kind of move
on to dive head first into unreal and
make my own smash brothers jake
unfortunately has some creative input
you're always going to be dealing with
producers and executives who are trying
to influence the project so that's
nothing new
oh god dang it nope oh my god
once again we've got numerous
participants
so far on the day
we're coming up on 27 minutes and again
just keeping track you know just letting
everybody know like i do
peter
i cannot believe i almost forgot are you
almost done
no
you're not
um i mean this this stuff is really hard
okay whatever we forgot something one of
the most fundamental things we do around
here
is wear bestie shoes courtesy of today's
sponsor bessie footwear
okay so i need you to put vesti shoes
into this game
and
it needs to be done like yesterday so
okay let me let me just
uh let me just load this up so jake this
is kind of what you're looking for right
oh that's perfect okay so a couple
things we're missing just a few things
all right uh input jump action that one
okay that needs to be changed to
100
waterproof because all of este shoes are
100 waterproof okay let me just
got it okay perfect dimetex material are
you familiar with this oh you want me to
make a dimetex material that needs to be
yeah because it keeps you cool in the
summer and warm in the winter okay it's
it's there all right almost done couple
more uh input touch definitely
definitely needs to be changed to highly
stretchy look at this here just hold
that
all the shoes need to be that stretchy
it's very stretchy okay hold this
stretch let me turn that up
okay good you look like you checked that
really fast are you sure i mean it's
really easy to pull up it was right
there you know i i'm sure here hold this
again okay this shoe oh you see the
bottom of it right yeah
yeah as the characters are playing and
jumping around we need to ensure that
they have
footwear
that keeps them gripped to the platform
whether it's slush or sleet or snow or
rain vesty shoes keep you gripped to the
ground right i let me know if this is
too grippy or not grippy enough that's
terrible
terrible yeah but if it was wearing
vestiges
he's getting it he's getting it uh okay
let me just make sure your nose are in
the right placement here um yeah yeah
they have to be closer together
okay and then just remember if you're
ready to experience the world's first
100 waterproof shoe and get 25 off of
your first order
just go to vessyfootwear.com
corridor crew remember that's
veseyfootwear.com
corridor crew for 25 off your first
order
um you get to keep that one really yeah
the other one's sam's yeah or just just
the one uh-huh enjoy cool yeah i mean
always good to have an extra shoe hey
good luck man
surprisingly difficult making a local
multiplayer game i'm just trying to wrap
my head around it watching a crazy
amount of tutorials on like 1.5 times
speed so i can speed through this
because we only have a week the things i
already know how to do in unreal are the
single player elements like creating a
character animating a character making
particles and that i'm not too worried
about the actual character creation
aspect what i am worried about is this
behind the scenes under the hood stuff
because it's complicated and it's a bit
harder to
so the main things i need to learn are
how to actually set up the local
multiplayer mechanic with having people
join a game spawn in choose their
characters and spawn into the level just
managing all of the different data for
each player because i'm not quite sure
how to do it for multiple people after
that i'll have to get into the fighting
mechanics how we register hits how we
registered damage how the camera flies
around the scene following everybody i
just got here this morning and peter was
like hey can you quickly make a corridor
office studio smash brothers arena and i
was like yeah we could do like hunter
street down below one of the studio
floors or non-corridor we could do i
know you're into like forest
stuff i love trees and leaves if we had
to make a corridor level it'd be the
studio downstairs and we were like yo
idea sam had a guy come in they actually
did a full scan of our studio i'm
actually going to use that as kind of
like a foundation to start dropping in
walls beams supports and all that stuff
and then bring it into unreal engine and
start throwing a bunch of textures on it
make it look nice get the lighting right
and everything and then peter he's gonna
work that magic and get it working with
the characters and stuff
perfect awesome
you're in peter's dramatic wide shot
this doesn't make any sense so i'm
working on this character selection
screen it's like sort of working but
each of us is assigned to a number like
chase is one
christian's two
daniel's three yeah and it keeps
skipping around it's like okay so if you
press the right arrow key adds plus one
to the character goes to the next
character right that makes sense very
simple math
i press play and it goes right to you
which is number three right again it
goes number four number five number six
but then if i press left
it goes to number three it like randomly
skips three like it doesn't make any
goddamn sense i think it's most
important to get something out though
you're right i'm getting two in the
weeds i just need to get out a version
that works like you're saying i get too
wrapped up in the details is this the
video where i finally learned my lesson
we'll see i guess
i guess so not so far but maybe starting
now i've learned my lessons
[Music]
someone playing smash for at least an
hour today
hey jake
jake times 60. jake do you want to play
that's how much money has been spent
today's playing smash
everyone is gone i guess it's smash time
now we're at 80 percent
hey peter
[Music]
wait you're playing
[Music]
look at this
[Music]
do that
change your character
i go back it works it works i figured it
out it was just a stupid problem a
little code error where you like add one
to the integer or whatever but then that
math was getting fired again by
something down the line and so i messed
everything up but i fixed that so now we
have a robust character selection screen
and i'm ready to dive into all of the
combat mechanics which is going to be
the fun stuff i'm really excited about
this what are you doing today
today i'm going to use this trusty 5d to
take some 3d scan photos of everybody in
the office i don't know if we're gonna
have characters for everybody but i at
least want to have the photos available
so i can make the 3d scans if i need to
all right let's get some 3d scans we're
using reality capture which is the
premier choice for photo scanning for
professionals and amateurs and everyone
in between it's so easy a baby could
photo scan their grandma i mean it
literally is like a one-click photo
stand so a baby could photoscan the
grandma if they wanted to i figured
maybe we'd just put your character in
there just in case you know in case you
feel like playing this is probably going
to encourage a lot of people to get back
to work a lot sooner i just don't ever
see myself how do i say stooping to that
level
you know
before i got a nintendo switch i was
really bad at smash brothers and i would
go to my friends houses and play it and
i'd always die first and kind of felt
left out but you know once i started
getting into it and kind of just
embracing the jank of myself i started
having a good time
good luck with that
[Music]
all right
so one of the things i find most
important about my job here at corridor
is being in touch with people's emotions
understanding what they need and what
they don't need because what people say
it's not always what they really feel
now when jake says stop playing smash
brothers and finish your work i think
what he's really saying is why didn't
you guys invite me why am i not playing
with you no one likes to be left out i
can only imagine that jake feels like
he's just missing out on a bunch of fun
i'm thinking that by peter making this
game and making a character for jake
it'll break down these barriers it'll
tear down these walls and jake will
finally be able to step over and get to
experience what we've all been
experiencing the community and the
camaraderie of smash bros
we'll see all right now that i got
everything i need character wise i need
to add fighting mechanics bouncing
mechanics player heads damage and a
winning mechanic and thankfully there's
a huge library of tutorials on the
internet for unreal but because this is
such a specific project i'm going to
have to code all this stuff myself the
first thing i need to figure out is the
player damage in smash brothers you have
a health bar that goes up it's a
percentage and the higher your
percentages the higher chance you have
to bounce around the map and fly off the
side and lose so what i had to do was
assign a damage value to each player and
then represent that damage value on
their player hud then we need some
actions to influence that variable so i
implemented a side punch and a neutral
punch the neutral punch is kind of just
to deal a little damage and keep your
opponent in place and the side punch is
to launch them and so for the launching
i need to establish a bouncing mechanic
you know player flies at a wall and you
need to get the angle at which they hit
the wall and get the inverted vector of
that and you need to keep calculating
that while slowly decreasing their speed
and that value is also influenced by the
damage that the player is being dealt so
that the higher damage they have and the
higher damage the attack is dealt onto
them the more they bounce and the higher
chance they have to fly out of the stage
and lose once we have the damage the
player hoods the fighting and the
bouncing implemented we can move on to
the winning mechanic where the last
opponent flies off the stage and the
last remaining character wins i've been
really fascinated by all this unreal
coding game making shenanigans and i
feel like our website
corridordigital.com is the perfect place
to put that kind of content so i'm going
to do a full breakdown of how i coded
this game and if you're interested grab
yourself a membership so you can watch
it's coming soon but until then i gotta
get to work
it's friday morning peter's been here
early he's been here late uh he clearly
hasn't showered in about three days
hey what's up
this is my final form i've made a ton of
progress over the last however many
hours just because of like all the
stupid stuff i was dealing with this
week but i like charged through that i
think i'm gonna have something good to
show today i'm excited i'm about 30
minutes away from a playable prototype
that you can like load up and it
actually doesn't drank out but i'm
around two hours away from something
really sweet my expectations of peter's
game is all over the place because the
idea of making a video game in one week
is pretty nuts let alone making smash
brothers in one week then again peter
reproduced an entire scene from harry
potter and cg in a week so i don't know
what to expect from peter anymore i
heard he made you a character
really
[Music]
is it is it smash time yet it's time
it's time
this is my game smush brethren i
couldn't get it running on its own so
it's running an unreal editor
[Music]
you've definitely managed to replicate
the
hey peter where's the messaging of uh
people that get back to work
[Music]
jake you can do this man you can be the
champion
that was awesome yeah
okay so that's what you guys are talking
about yeah i think that was so much fun
that you know i don't even care that uh
you can't it doesn't encourage people to
necessarily go back to work i think you
did a great job and i learned something
here and that's the value of feeling
like you're a part of something thanks
for that man that really means a lot to
me it means a lot that my game had such
a profound effect on you and i'm talking
more playing
this is the first game i've ever made so
like having people play my game in a
group and hearing them yelling and
cheering it's a great feeling as hard as
this was to make i definitely want to do
it again because this is super rewarding
feel free to leave a comment suggesting
any other unreal projects we should
tackle we're definitely going to be
making a bunch of other stuff in unreal
after this and uh if you like this feel
free to subscribe we'll probably be
making some more crazy [ __ ] and unreal
so
yeah thanks for watching